surprise it's a Thursday video this is
so embarrassing for you you had no idea
Wow Wow surprise come on oh okay I broke
it well get used to Thursday videos
because something amazing is happening
I'm announcing my brand new series a
brand new show is called Diana brain can
I get a very weak but well-intentioned
drumroll wow I didn't even announce it
yet
writing with grace that should have been
the confetti maybe then that's right
writing with grace so sexy right so
provocative and wrong Branko
self-explanatory the title the title of
the series writing with grace is very
self-explanatory the next eight week you
and our suite together collectively as a
unit will be writing a can I get that
okay maybe I will just I'm Novello wow
that sounds sexy right what's a novella
novella if you do not know is a long
short story or a short novel or a
normal-size novella I'm not working with
a teeny hello labs
to bring this show to you myself along
with some other really amazing content
creators on YouTube are working with HD
hello lab to create these awesome
original who will file you need other
adjective worthy series that will be
rolling out throughout the year and this
is my series writing with grace yeah
high five myself you with it
you guys owns myself will be writing in
eighth chapter novella
it's called freak week and guess what
I've already written the first chapter
for us ah think apocalypse think
highschool think young pink dogs all of
those things you want to go fact-check
girl in it you can go read chapter one
over on our Wattpad page Wattpad comm
slash writing with i would love if you
went over to our Wattpad page and read
chapter one of freak week if you don't
have a Wattpad profile already please
make sure you register i wrote chapter
one and you guys will be writing
chapters two through seven yeah seamless
easy choreography it'll be a new episode
of writing with grace every thursday
right here on my youtube channel in
which i will be giving you prompts so
that you guys can write the new chapter
of our novella like a real app writing
workshop by that i mean each week I'll
be giving you small things that you need
to include in the next chapter of freak
we it give you things like you have to
include a space monkey and the phrase
get rekt - 2 3 2 2 3 2 2 3 times because
then tells me that you guys love using
that phrase get read that it's a very
popular useful phrase and that it keeps
me young
by saying yet but those are not the
actual prompts those are just example
next week we will be going over the
actual prompts you I know this is a lot
of information but this is a very
exciting lot of information so I hope
that you feel as excited as I do look
how excited I am
each week I'll be going through your
submissions on our hashtag riding with
grace commit that to memory we will be
using that for the next eight weeks
hashtag get used to it
don't use that hashtag use hashtag
riding with grace I'll be using the
hashtag to choose a winning chapter that
continues freak week but I will also be
commenting on some of my favorite
submissions each week my favorite writer
trends and themes everything is fair
game
but don't think every Thursday just
gonna be me reading something that
doesn't interest you written by someone
that's not you that's not what it's
gonna be
because finishing this novella is up to
you and then we're going to rinse and
repeat that process all the way to
chapter 7 and then I will book and our
novella deal with it by writing chapter
8 I will be writing chapter 1 and 8 you
guys will be writing chapters 2 through
7
now finally the part that has got me
super juiced dan told me that you guys
say juice and I just now after saying it
do not believe it when our
groundbreaking future novella Freak week
is completely finished we'll be doing a
live reading of the entire thing at
VidCon
Wow it's like myself along with all my
famous friends will be reading freak
week live start to finish at VidCon
bringing yours and my words to life Amos
friends like you guys start speculation
start rumors who could it be how
exciting is this you guys take a second
and scream at your computer screen with
me right now 1 2 3 ha so while I go back
to following some more French bulldogs
on Instagram here's what I need you guys
to do I need you to create your walk
path profile
I need Diane to stop dropping things on
the ground I need you to go over and
file our Wattpad page walk dead calm
such writing with also you should really
go over to our Wattpad page because it
has all the official rules should be
extremely boring for me to tell you here
so please go over and read those they're
very important I don't want you to lose
any of your submissions because you
didn't follow the rules
yeah thank you very so much for
listening I am genuinely very excited
about this series I hope that you are -
see you guys next Thursday with more
reading with grace also I'll be here on
my youtube channel doing normal stuff
that's not getting compromised it's just
getting enhanced I don't know